[Music]
in vacation ruined news ruin Oh ruin
pimples yeah or it's just like it was
ruined it went to caca submitted by
going bananas ba na na s this beat is
who did it ah she's a like a Harajuku
girl is she hurt
what's the funny I can't remember I
haven't seen it don't know no doubt
don't speak okay don't speak what the
[ __ ]
David Onley licit R&B David you don't
know when Stefani do I know who Quinn
Stefani is I don't remember her face
anymore
how can you say you know someone just
music look she's saying you the most
popular the only reason why I know that
song is because at this Key Club
convention at this KidCo convention I
went to write there was his girl a
friend of mine who can't oh dang she bad
as [ __ ] um this girl this friend of mine
she can spell bananas and that she was
mad funny she was like his beat is
bananas that song hilarious I still
can't spell bananas a woman feels she
was wrongly profiled after being
mistaken for a human trafficking victim
on a Delta flight oh and please explain
that's why social media oh yeah that
word prostitute like that it was like a
victim - hey you look like a hooker I'm
not yes you are I think they're trained
to spot that well-trained
it's the flight attendants yeah you know
that cuz there was that one are you ap
bleed twice if you need help for
instance if it's there accompanied by
like a considerably older guy and the
curtain around the chicks like that's my
grandpa 12 year old Thai girl yeah
wearing fishnet stockings in a miniskirt
[ __ ] what do you call those things
with the spikes and [ __ ]
yeah like the blink twice chakra what a
spike hmm yeah they're they're trained
for this but I'm here but yeah so this
woman her name is Stephanie she's from
Atlanta she went to Cancun with her
friends
for her 26th birthday and so flying back
from Cancun on the Delta flight when
they arrived into Atlanta they were
greeted by a buddy what it's sad the
situation is really sad but it's also
kind of funny yeah Wyatt I don't know
what's funny yeah I haven't heard her
sing so it's kind of like you're not
even a hooker but everyone thinks you're
a [ __ ] hooker how long she's been
pregnant it's not just a sex lady yeah
sex traffic but you're being framed for
something like but it's like that it's
like they're priming you for something
that you never yeah it's like they're so
convinced yeah they're so convinced yes
apparently while she was on this flight
someone else noticed that her and her
friend weren't on warrant in possession
of their passports and so they alerted
the flight attendant and then the flight
attendant alerted the officials when
they got to the airport and so they were
saying she's saying Stephanie saying
that she was questioned for more than an
hour because she was playing in on
Thanksgiving too so she was trying to
tell them like what's happening like why
like they didn't tell for a long time
why they were questioning yeah yeah and
so she was like you know I'm missing my
Thanksgiving dinner that this isn't cool
like you know I just got back from my
fascinator coming in on the day off yes
yes she had a work pay bills she's like
I just want to go home to my family I'm
missing my Thanksgiving dinner and so
she was interviewed I'm gonna show you
guys a clip of her explaining your
situation what if she's a really good
like she does not look like a hook and
it's not that's like librarian yeah she
doesn't look like a like a victim she's
like a Berkeley student yeah she looks
like she works like a Yelper shop Yelper
yep
today I woke up and went for coffee go
ahead I know human trafficking is huge
with within the ADA community right and
that's the only reason why I could see
you stalking me and the
I was in a dress I was in a dress with a
cardigan and some boots and I think
that's totally appropriate to fly on the
airplane with and are you crying though
and honestly I think it's just the fact
that I'm Asian she's Asian and we're two
little girls on the plane you know mind
your own business but still that just
looks like a red flag for everyone like
I was hoping for just one country and I
just I kept telling them I just wanted
to go home for my family Thanksgiving
dinner and that they were making me late
baby's hair they just left my family you
can't take that back
because I was a part of it yeah seen a
Dear John justify my laughing okay I
think it's kind of sweet that
Thanksgiving dinner is that [ __ ]
important to her and her family yeah I'm
just jealous cuz it doesn't make me cry
if I missed it with my family it's like
[ __ ] it there's just another dinner I
think we'll meet it a little bit more
comical at least was just the jump cut
cuz it was like her voices right and
then it just went too so that was like
whoa why did you guys edit it that way
like I don't know it was no warning
it just it comes off comical because the
way she's crying it sounds like the
event was a lot more it should have been
explained more horrific
so her exploit was very mundane so the
way she was like they were just keeping
me there and saying I couldn't go dad
and it so I'm waiting for that they were
yelling a mess she was trying to tell
him that she just want to go home and
that they would laugh but they were the
officials were just laughing at her and
I get that hurt that's [ __ ] up because
if you're if you're grabbing her up
because you're worried for her you think
she's a victim but you're [ __ ] with
her like laughing at her
that's just harassment she was saying to
the whole passport thing wasn't even
true like her and her friend did have
passports on them yeah see that's I
think if she would have except if I
would have thought that Dennis I know
this is [ __ ] up but it just sounded
like they just took her side as I think
anyway here
that's what it came off man just just
sit down no just sit down it's like what
the hell you just have a seat I want
Thanksgiving food sales Thank You
Think's give it away she's good she's
treated more like a criminal rather than
a victim oh that's all you know what's
weird though most I think most sex
trafficking victims are foreign
nationals they're not Asian Americans
she doesn't have an accent exactly get
the profile just a tiny wiggle coming
from Mexico to Cancun
no [ __ ] makes people hate Asian
people over there come on now what no we
don't what's the story I don't [ __ ]
know I'm joking he's just try to like
move on please please I'm just gonna do
something right so what's gonna she is
she suing that Department of who was it
the Department of TSA or what was it
yeah wore these boogieman that [ __ ] with
that how the US Customs and Border
Patrol amine grass so what happened over
here not over there
it happened in Atlanta oh [ __ ] yeah but
she speaks English though dude that's
[ __ ] dumb you're like hold on Ching
Chang I can't understand what you're
saying I need to go home whoa get a
translator yeah Delta I was just they
came out with the statement just saying
that they have been proactively fighting
human trafficking since 2011 and that
all of their flight attendants are
trained very recent what do you live
Wow that's been going on for a long time
just [ __ ] barely started it's
basically slave trade people it's pretty
pretty [ __ ] bad though damn and then
so it would be cool we start fighting
human trafficking okay yeah I get to the
2011 we'll just add it to the roster I
mean that the perfect position to look
for human trafficking traveling the
flight attendants we can see that and
then plus we've talked about stories
where they've actually saved people from
yeah you know what's [ __ ] up though
like I just heard about this from a
friend who watched a documentary on this
[ __ ] but you don't like you know they
have like these little girls I was just
imagining if I had a kid and what it
would make me so this guy went
undercover and he went into like one of
those like prostitution places where
they were actually giving little girls
away to get [ __ ] of [ __ ] and this
little girl she said that what she saw
she started crying I started like
cheering up to I don't have a kid but
the little girl she'd just look lifeless
and she was like I forgot what the
gesture was but it was like do you want
something something and it's basically I
say do you want a [ __ ] and it's a
little cold dressed in like sexual you
know the dudes just bawling because it's
like it reminds him of his kid he's like
yeah but you want to just take them away
and then their punishment if they don't
get a tip would be like the madam would
like take chili peppers and then rub it
on their [ __ ] yeah where is this this is
like Kyle Anderson filagot bomb man
Bessel Saad mom yeah it's like some sad
stuff and that little girl is just
asking this older guy from but he's
obviously he's like undercover like
bawling you know I think I seen the same
one they called a bum bomb or something
or something like yeah yeah yeah I seen
this it's like he was uh he was [ __ ]
sexual tourism but pedophilia kids are
[ __ ] trained to do that [ __ ] it's so
huge a huge advocate against all of this
stuff and it's like proactively using
his fame for it real world tactical
Ashton Kutcher yeah I was just like what
yeah what do you think that even that
big no real real tactical Jack he's a
predator hunter yeah that's why I like I
like the he's on our side
yeah yeah but no I'm just saying he's
just not as he doesn't happen because if
he was a pedophile be too scary yeah
I'ma be that would be one pedophile
really difficult to take down it's like
if a lion was a pedophile yeah dog you
know why couldn't you be a baboon or
something dude what the vocal rip your
face okay why couldn't you be a teeter
or something
you know a snail Louis
Jasin Kutcher hates pedophiles he's he
like he's a huge advocate like trying to
stop all of that story and I go what is
it like nonprofit something yeah it's
some crazy [ __ ] though man
my friend used to work at a legal
brothel mm-hmm I think that brothels are
bad they're legal brothels and women no
they're just homes and then like I think
the girls were probably like sex traffic
because they're all like from China and
stuff that's sad but there's like a very
very big distinction between
prostitution and human you know I
actually got really really upset
recently because there's this massage
place that I've been going to and I went
there like three or four times right and
then I brought my friend who's a very
muscular man when he went there the
worker sexually harassed him and I was
so [ __ ] pissed because I went there
three times and nobody touched me like
that
it is very offensive she was like
rubbing her [ __ ] on the back of his
head oh yeah and he was like you know
it's like when you go there like do they
[ __ ] sexually harass you and I was
like absolutely not what the [ __ ] they
never touched they never touched me like
that I gave them a 1-star because I
didn't get sexually harassed they would
have happy endings for women they do go
I mean exist now they do no not legally
legally right I was reading on in a
Cosmo you know and you're playing people
leave magnet their magazine is [ __ ] but
it was this lady who was trying to get
finger banged at a [ __ ] thing for
like you know that same experience and
she was telling giving advice on how to
do it like there's actually signs so she
tried a couple times and this guy was
just like nope I love my job man I love
my job and other times like she's just
kind of like oh my god like Papa the dad
that grazes his dick and then he's like
oh it's like that huh
and then he [ __ ] her on the table a
little extreme I'm talking about just
like a giant even need to see the face
just like through all these fingers
glory hole oh that's what you want yeah
I don't want to see anyone scripture
[ __ ] up against a wall
I'm native I don't know what so you want
to have to just come out just that sound
oh my god it's already medical sounding
though it's it's not romantic or
anything it just sounds like it's all
physical so after you get your massage
and you get that finish yeah I think
that would be the ultimate relaxation
exactly that would be and then just mind
body everything I mean they just give
you options of what fingers and they
give you a hand formation then you
choose one is that what it that what you
want I just want a torso with no head I
just don't want to see someone's face
because a lot of my attraction comes in
to like play when if I'm not attracted
to that person I can be attracted to
their torso and down judgin want to see
your [ __ ] face I don't wanna see your
little gap-toothed teeth I didn't even
notice it's just one I don't see it
David thank you don't be fingering it's
[ __ ] these brown [ __ ] and arm
tattoos that's [ __ ] do this yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] bags anyway [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] don't even know what an
ethnicity you want to [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait so you're making us out to
be cooler than what we are are you still
here shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]